[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain a japanese superhero film
called inuyashiki spoilers ahead watch
out and take care
ichiro inuyashiki is a normal salaryman
doing his best to keep his family happy
but his family takes all his effort for
granted and often treats him like trash
ichiro has recently bought a new house
in a better neighborhood for their sake
his daughter mary and son takeshi are
delighted to see a big house and mistake
it for their own they accidentally try
to enter it but are told their house is
the tiny one by the side it is the best
ichiro could have done with the money he
saved for years but the children do not
care in an attempt to lighten the mood
he tells them he bought their favorite
food but no one pays attention instead
they go out to dinner leaving ichiro
behind to eat alone one day ichiro works
overtime and returns home late in a dark
alleyway he sees a group of muggers
beating a man for money he thinks of
helping the man but is too cowardly to
actually do it just when he turns around
he sees mary watching him in
disappointment she reminds him that he
is a disgusting coward before storming
off back home ichiro sits in front of
their house thinking about life suddenly
a dog walks toward him wanting to be
petted its caller says her name is
hanako please take care of her ichiro
pities the dog but his wife wants him to
get rid of it she also hands him his
medical report which says that he needs
one more checkup the next day ichiro
goes to the hospital and finds out he
has third stage cancer it has spread
throughout his body which gives him only
a few months to live overwhelmed by the
news he calls his wife but she ends the
call before he can tell her the news
while his children do not even pick up
their phones later ichiro takes hanukkah
on a walk and wonders if his family will
even cry when they know about his cancer
with a heavy heart he leaves hanukkah by
the side of the road and runs away to a
park to his surprise the animal follows
him there seeing that he is the only one
who cares about him ichiro cries while
apologizing to the dog some seconds
later he notices another man sitting on
a park bench in front of him suddenly a
bright light flashes in the sky and
continues getting bigger something large
falls from the sky hitting ichiro and
the man beside him causing their
immediate death the next day however
ichiro wakes up in the park right where
he had landed yesterday hanukko is
beside him on the ground he picks up his
glasses but realizes he can see clearly
even without them not knowing what to do
he continues about his day at home his
hand turns into a weapon-like device and
vomits out the breakfast he had just
eaten he is even more horrified when his
face disintegrates to reveal an electric
system inside his head one part after
another his entire body turns into a
machine it turns out that the strange
object killed ichiro last night it was a
mistake on the part of the aliens who
were flying the object so they revived
him as a machine with emotions he now
possesses superhuman strength and of the
power of any machinery in the world all
that potential and he'll probably just
end up browsing tiktok the man who was
with him yesterday named hiro also
received the superpower he goes to his
friend naoyuki's house and shoots a bird
with his fingers he then brings a
surprise to naoyuki to a parking lot and
showcases how he can move vehicles with
his mind now yuki is baffled by hiro's
power and feels like he is in a dream
meanwhile ichiro is still confused about
this morning on his way home he sees an
injured pigeon on the side of the road
as he goes to pick it up his hands heal
the bird and it flies away just then his
heightened hearing power causes him to
hear a mother pleading with doctors to
save her son he follows the sound and
finds a sick kid on the hospital bed as
he touches his face the kid starts to
heal like the pigeon ichiro gladly tells
the kid that he has recovered and
returns home happily the next day now
yuki is bullied by his classmates hiro
intervenes and tries to kill the bully
until now yuki stops him now yuki sees
that the power has made hiro violent
which scares him chion is a girl from
hiro's class who has a crush on him that
day she tells him that she likes him
leaving hiro in shock after that we are
introduced to his mother who is a
waitress in a restaurant his father is a
rich man who left his mother for another
woman hiro doesn't like his father but
still goes to meet him and his other
family for dinner hiro's step siblings
like him and are always excited to see
him but he could never like them back
thinking of his poor mother it is almost
midnight when hiro is walking back home
he hears the sound of a family which
reminds him of his dad's new life
enraged with anger he breaks into the
family's home kills the parents and
chases the daughter down the hallway
while he uses his power for revenge
ichiro heals many children in the
hospital the murder makes headlines the
next day since no bullets were found now
yuki is afraid his friend is behind the
murder when they meet hiro offers him a
large amount of money the boys get into
an argument because of it now yuki
cannot believe how easy it is for hiro
to kill innocent people he does not want
to be his friend anymore hiro is
devastated by naoyuki's comment he
returns home still in shock only to find
that his mother has pancreatic cancer he
begins to cry in her arms promising her
that he will not let her die meanwhile
at ichiro's home his son is found
stealing money from his mother's purse
and mary says she doesn't want to go to
university the household is in chaos
when ichiro tells everyone that he will
protect all of them laughing at her
father's stupidity mary tells him that
takeshi is being bullied at school and
her mother has an affair with a younger
man she wants to make him feel worse
than she does which works efficiently
that night ichiro cries alone in his
room suddenly he hears now yuki praying
to god to stop his friend from killing
people ichiro realizes he is talking
about hiro and flies to him they talk
for a while and figure out that ichiro
and hiro were reformed by some form of
higher life now yuki offers to train
ichiro so he can stop hiro from killing
more people although they possess the
same powers hiro can use his abilities
more efficiently than ichiro the next
day they meet in an abandoned garage
where now yuki teaches ichiro to shoot
through his fingers after trying
repeatedly ichiro finally succeeds but
needs more practice meanwhile hiro and
his mother are at the doctors where he
tells them that her cancer cells have
disappeared both the doctor and hero's
mother are surprised on their way back
home six policemen surround them they
are there to interrogate hiro about the
murders as his mother asks him what her
son has done hiro makes a run for it the
policemen catch him but he is able to
escape using his powers eventually he
shoots three of the policemen dead it is
clear to them that hiro is the one
behind the murders his pictures are all
over the news the next day the same day
his friend shion finds him on a bridge
and brings him home she doesn't care
about the people he has killed and
allows him to stay with her for as long
as she wants she lives with her
grandmother which makes it easier for
hero to hide in their house meanwhile
ichiro has mastered shooting from his
fingers as days go by they realize that
water acts as fuel to ichiro's power but
he is allergic to sodium water since
hiro is in hiding the media starts
attacking his mother she gets death
threats on the internet and is harassed
on the streets hiro sees his mother on
the tv and can't help but cry when the
guilt is too much for her to handle she
commits the unthinkable hiro gets to
know about this through a news channel
and is devastated his sadness changes
into anger and he makes it his mission
to kill every single person who talked
bad about his mother he soon finds out
that he can shoot people through their
phones and computers using the internet
he hunts down every single person who
comments on his mother and kills them
through their devices ichiro has become
a troll hunter that night hiro shows
cheyenne his robotic arm to prove that
he is not a human he takes her in his
arms and flies with the help of his
parachute while flying over the
skyscrapers he promises to be there with
her forever the unsolved murders shake
the entire nation making people go into
a frenzy five people who survived the
attempted murder tell the press that
they saw hiro on their phone screens
before they were shot that night
cheyenne is in her kitchen when suddenly
a group of snipers starts firing hiro
kills all of them but is unable to save
a dying cheyenne the house is surrounded
by the police after cheyenne hiro has no
one to live for his head goes numb and
is filled with the feeling of vengeance
within seconds he flies away through the
window the police cannot even comprehend
what just happened ichiro finds out what
hiro is doing and urges his family to
not use smartphones and stay at home for
the day but as usual they do not obey
him hiro hacks every single smartphone
in tokyo and tells the people that he
has declared war against japan he plans
to kill all 120 million people until no
one is left after the declaration he
doesn't waste time before firing openly
through the billboard hundreds of people
die within a minute and the city plunges
into chaos meanwhile ichiro and now yuri
take over hiro and hack all the
computers they inform everyone to stay
off their smartphones and computers
their plan works and people stop using
their phones hiro finally realizes there
is another person like him and decides
to change his plan a bit he starts
dropping several missiles on different
parts of the city as the chaos
intensifies ichiro figures out hiro's
location and rushes to stop him the two
come face to face on the top of a
skyscraper ichiro tries to calm hiro
down but to no avail they fly through
the sky of tokyo while battling hiro's
missile injures many innocent people one
of them being mary ichiro hears mary
begging for help while he is on the run
after an intense fight they land on top
of a building ichiro again requests that
hiro stop but he refuses when hiro tries
to drink water from a bottle ichiro
shoots it down and slyly drops the
bottle with sodium water in it not
knowing the effects of sodium hiro chugs
the water down he then bombards ichiro
with missiles in the air he is about to
kill ichiro with the last shot when the
sodium water makes him weak while
falling down from the height hiro
realizes that he is the villain of the
story in the meantime ichiro comes down
to save his daughter and finds her
amidst the remains of a building she is
on the verge of dying when he uses his
powers to save her but as they celebrate
hiro arrives again and kicks ichiro mary
also gets shot in the process hiro
overpowers ichiro before throwing mary
out the window this angers ichiro and
multiplies his robotic powers both hiro
and ichiro leap at each other but this
time ichiro's strength overpowers heroes
and disassembles his arm following that
ichiro catches mary in the air and saves
her mary realizes she has been wrong
about her father and watches him save
other people in admiration a week after
the incident the press declares hiro
dead ichiro is now respected in his
family mostly by his daughter and all it
took was to gain some superpowers and
murder a guy subscribe for more videos
like this turn on notifications and
leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching